我可能那个刚工作了几年，
然后我想跟我菲姐聊一下我的生活和工作，
就是未来的那个方向，
就是先说一下我本人的情况，
就是我是95年的，
然后是山西晋中人，
身高160，
体中有108，
是研究生学历，
然后在那个浙江一线城市一个事业单位工作，
家庭情况的话是我有一家四口，
然后我父母的话是初中学历，
然后之前的话还比较好，
现在的话就一直在打工，
和我弟弟的话是大专，
就是在北方一个城市，
呃，
戴绿帽子的那种工作，
我们家的话就是很传统的北方的那种家庭，
就表面上其实说那个男女平等什么的，
这意义还是就是给弟弟买房买什么的，
就是父母向家奋斗的目标，
因为我们俩都工作了嘛，
然后我这边的话主要就是自给自足这样子，
然后我现在嗯，
就是下边有一一辆车啊，
别的就没有了，
然后我的工作的话性质比较特殊，
不知道龙飞姐有没有那个指导考古这个工作吧，
知道我还有比如说在网上刷到那些就是考古工作人员，
工作挺辛苦的，
这工作或者什么风餐露宿的工作环境挺不容易的呢，
但在其在。
还好很多了，
我在浙江这边基本的那个物质生活条件还可以的，
然后各方面基础设施也很好，
交通也很方便，
就是可能不像以前那种老前辈比较艰苦卓绝的那种感觉，
就我们的话，
呃，
工作的话就在工地上管吃管住，
主要是这个事情，
所以我就要长期在省内出差，
都要在省内各个地方，
就可能不在我的工作的单位的那个城市，
所以就就是很麻烦，
但是我很喜欢这个工作，
然后我在这个工作就是呃，
26岁研究生毕业以后就直接进到这个单位从事这份工作，
然后我也很热爱，
然后一直在不断的学习，
积累自己的知识，
所以就有一点比较小的成就吧，
就领导这方面还比较认可，
我觉得工作方面还是很有信心的，
反正也在初期嘛，
现在我们这个行业竞争也很激烈，
然后扩编就扩的比较多，
然后同事也很多，
可能未来在这个升升职或者是评职称方面其实还会比较难，
就这个事情，
因为我今年95年了嘛，
也30岁了，
所以考虑到就未来伴侣的这个事情的话，
目前为止是有一个正在交往的对象想跟龙菲姐说一下。
基本基本信息是就是他是河南信阳人，
然后有两个姐姐，
父母就是也是农民，
然后他们一直在搞那个苗木，
但是他母亲是去前年去世了，
就生病去世了，
然后父亲的话就还是在，
嗯从事苗木，
但是最近这个房地产董飞姐也知道，
所以他这个收入就没有以前那么高，
然后基本上一年的话也没什么收入，
就这个样子，
他父亲给他付的就是在这个，
呃，
浙江这个杭州付的首付，
但是房贷的话有100个就比较多，
然后他现在的房子的情况就是租出去了，
然后也没有装修，
他在他的员工宿舍里边住，
然后他也是研究生学历，
有四年的一个男生，
然后身高有178cm吧，
就140斤，
比较高层，
对对对，
很标准，
然后他是在就是大厂里边搞研发的，
然后他也是研究生毕业以后就进那个厂吧，
但是他现在这个经济各方面形式不景，
其他的行业其实也跟房地产有一定的关系，
所以他现在可能也就年轻20个吧，
就这个样子，
然后我就感觉我们俩的话已经见过双方父父母了，
我父母的话，
就我母亲还是比。
比较支持我的各方面的决定，
然后包括我的工作，
我的生活，
还有未来的那个择偶的各方面，
但是我自己可能就一一个是我这个工作真的需要长期出差，
然后我又是一个特别专心于工作的人，
就我就很喜欢在那个工地上待着，
然后口户我去发报告这个事情，
所以吧，
我感觉在择偶方面很少有男生能接受这个女孩子一直在外出差这个事情觉得的话，
就感觉他父亲的话，
可能也是属于那种比较传统的那种男权的家庭吧，
就是比较催婚未育什么的，
但是他还好，
他自己比较有想法，
然后也没说什么，
就是说我们先过好两个人自己的生活，
因为我们两个人事业都在上升期，
他也很努力，
然后我也很努力，
所以我们可能也就周六日见面，
然后平时的话，
我就一直在忙工作，
半夜也在看简报什么的，
然后最近一直在忙这个，
他也是经常会有一段时间加班，
但是我们俩尽量挤出周六日的时间来，
然后就是聚一下，
就这个样子，
目前为止是这样，
所以想让龙菲姐帮我分析一下，
就是这个情况，
你说他的父亲是一个父权，
就是父权的。
当一个家长制，
那他的那两个姐姐结婚了吗？
他两个姐姐也就是初中学历，
然后学历也比较低，
然后他大姐的话就在他本地已经结婚了，
然后就一个人带两个孩子，
因为他姐夫也在上海打工，
就这样子，
然后她二姐的话也是初中学历，
就是老公也是去年才结婚的，
九三年的吧，
然后跟着她的老公在外边开超市，
这样子就我就感觉他们家庭的这个学历可能普遍都比较低，
就是沟通的话可能会比较难一点，
不像我父母就是那么好说，
就是有些工作啊，
或者是生活上的事情是这样子，
他们可能就比较我也不是说歧视他们家庭啊，
不是这个意思，
就是他们可能也见的比较少，
然后就是比较局限在他们那个小县城里面，
所以他们可能也是对翠生催婚这个事情也比较那个就是支持他父亲的意见，
但是我们会想起，
比如说呃，
以我们两个现在的经济实力，
然后要去还房贷，
然后要去给房子装修，
要去置办结婚的东西，
去结婚的话，
我感觉我们俩的呃能力还是没有达到的，
然后的话呢，
因为工作都在上升期，
我们俩的这个就是。
第一笔就不在这个上面，
假设你们两个人共同去组建家庭，
你们将来是打算在哪里生活呀？
就在杭州，
在杭州生活，
他买的那个房子，
有100万房贷的那个房子是在杭州吗？
就是在杭州的郊区，
嗯，
他首付是付了多少呢？
60多70个，
这60多70多基本上是男生的父亲给的钱，
对不对对，
是的，
就男生父亲能给儿子买房子花六七十万，
这父亲也算是非常有能力了，
尤其是他苗龄这方面，
那就是很辛苦了啊，
我觉得他父亲对他还是很上心的，
也比较支持他所在杭州定居，
父亲就一直催他买房，
他可能个人压力比较大，
他觉得他背着房贷，
然后我也说，
因为我可能有公积金什么的，
以后可能也不是什么太那个的事情，
但是想到100万也不是个小数目吧，
所以我还是一个月的房贷是还多少啊，
1000多6000吧，
他就是你现在男朋友，
他自己的工资一个月是多少啊，
他年薪20个，
一个月就1万，
然后可能有年终奖的，
有绩效啊，
这种我挺应该也是属于比较节约的啊，
是的是的，
他自己是住宿舍的，
那你们等于是接触的过程。
当中并没有实实在在的共同在一起生活的这样一个经历，
是不是也有，
就是周六日，
我们就只能周六日，
因为他那个宿舍其实是相当于租给他们住的嘛，
然后就是一个是单独的房间，
然后有呃，
厨房卫生间，
然后卧室客厅都有的，
所以我们俩周六日会一起做饭，
就是一起厨卫在一起玩，
就是我感觉他很好的，
就是个人的生活能力很强，
他自己就是也不能说抠门吧，
反正我感觉他计划的很好，
就是在消费这个方面，
然后还有就比如说平时他会自己做饭，
然后自己打扫房间，
自己收拾卫生，
这个方面，
我感觉我可以这么理解吗？
就是你本人对男生是比较满意的，
只是说现在有点顾虑男方的这个家庭，
可以这么理解吗？
对，
因为就是我这个工作的特殊性，
就我可能考虑到，
比如说未来真的有孩子的话，
是要看孩子这个问题，
因为他母亲已经去世了嘛，
然后就只剩他父亲一个人，
然后他父亲平时跟他也就那个电话上联络一下，
也不会来这边了，
我爸妈的话就很传统，
我感觉如果要是我弟弟没有孩子，
可以帮我看，
但是我感觉如。
如我弟有了孩子，
我们俩可能就要靠自己吧，
其实我觉得啊，
这个事情，
嗯，
婆婆去世了，
不能帮你看孩子，
这个事情她是有两面性的，
另一方面好像呃呃，
婆婆不能帮我看孩子啊，
怎么怎么样的，
那另一方面你也没有婆媳矛盾了呀，
他的这个父亲现在还在做着苗龄这方面的工作，
那呃，
我可以大胆揣测一下，
他父亲应该还是比较硬朗的是吧，
但是也不会和你们生活在一起的，
其实你能够预料的到的10年都是你和你的这个男朋友去相处的，
所以我觉得像如果说你男朋友本身没有什么恶习，
人也很好，
很有生存能力，
也比较踏实，
也比较节约，
也不会手大脚的花钱，
其实以后的幸福生活是要靠你们两个人去缔造的，
你如果说带孩子你特别呃，
需要有人帮你带的话，
你就趁着你的弟弟还没结婚呗，
趁着你的妈妈还有这个空闲空档呗，
因为你也到这个年纪了，
30岁了是吧？
然后至于说你说他爸爸有点大男子主义，
但我觉得一个父亲能够给孩子拿出六七十万来买房子的话，
有点大男子主义还是可以忍一忍的啊，
只要他不跟我生活在一起，
对我的生活指手划脚的话，
他在自己的呃人际关系里，
在自己的圈子里有点大男子主义的话，
那是他的事情哦，
而且。
你们两个人慢慢的，
如果说工资凑在一块儿花的话，
其实等孩子出生了，
假设你的妈妈要去给你的弟弟看孩子的话，
等孩子30岁了，
孩子就可以上托儿所了，
嗯，
找一个那种，
小时工接接孩子，
送送孩子也不是不可以，
就是目前聊下来的话，
我并没有捕捉到男方有任何的不妥，
有任何的这个情绪上的问题呀，
性格上的缺陷呀，
或者说男方有什么恶习呀，
目前是没有捕捉到的，
目前就是这男方哪哪都挺好是吧，
就是目前为止，
就相处过程中我觉得还可以，
没有什么就是太大的，
就是陋习，
或者是比较不好的生活习惯，
那你们俩啊，
就是好好的生活规划上，
就是平时节约一点，
平时举个例子啊，
有1万的包，
有一天的包，
一天的包也能背是吧，
有那个八五百的口红，
有70块钱的口红，
70块钱的口红也质量也挺好，
有那种嗯，
几千块钱的一套衣服对吧，
有两三百一套的衣服，
一两百两三百也挺好，
就说你俩节约一点的话，
这日子是挺好的，
嗯，
没事，
姐姐，
我们就是工地里，
每天在考古工地就穿个冲锋衣，
这也没啥，
我就知道周两日，
比如说见他的时候，
我。
可能才会稍微注重一下自己的，
我感觉要呃，
就是站到他平时的话，
我就冲风衣，
然后运动裤，
就在工地上干活，
戴个草帽啊这样子，
因我都不属于那种特别物质，
特别喜欢那个奢侈品的人的话，
请天公资凑一块过日子是没问题的呀，
就是我可能我就是怕我年纪小，
然后想不周全，
我是想着我工作性质比较特殊，
然后我又不想放弃，
就是因为以后成家生孩子放弃自己的工作，
然后也不想说，
因为这个工作好像就是可能对不起自己的家人，
他爸爸可能确实挺负责任，
为了他也把自己所有积蓄拿出来给他买房子，
我觉得已经很不错了，
如果要是说以后再装修什么各方面还要再去麻烦他爸爸的话，
我感觉也不太现实，
也不太好，
然后的话，
呃，
就是像什么彩礼什么就也就没什么，
然后我就在想，
如果这个事情我能就是比如说能接受的话，
我以后会不会后悔，
或者觉得自己这个事情我感觉也不能说对错吧，
反正看什么经营这个事情，
但是我就是想问一下龙飞姐姐这样有经验的人，
哦，
我坦率的讲啊，
你的这个工作性质人家。
也会考量的，
不能照顾孩子，
不能照顾家里，
一天到处跑考古啊什么的，
人家也会考量的，
对的，
你男朋友要是不嫌弃你的这个工作性质，
我觉得就挺好的，
谢谢老飞姐来啊啊啊，
老菲姐再见，
王菲姐对你们就是净说大实话啊，
说大实话就是男方，
男方在找对象的时候，
她也会考虑，
就是女方的工作轻松吗？
女方以后能够带孩子吗？
女女方以后有更多的时间陪伴孩子，
照顾孩子嘛，
其实男方也会考虑这个问题，
就如果说咱们的工作性质是既定的，
对吧，
风餐露宿的，
有的时候要出差啊，
去别的地方啊，
没有那么多时间精力照顾家照顾孩子，
就是男方已经在这件事情上做了让步和妥协了，
我直播间应该也有男同学，
男同学啊，
可能你二十几岁的时候，
你在找一个对象，
你只看她漂亮吗？
身材好吗？
跟他在一起开心吗？
你对她有冲动吗？
你只看这个，
那等你到30岁的时候，
你真的找人结婚的时候，
你会不会考虑女方？
嗯，
能不能照顾家，
能不能照顾小孩，
有没有足够多的时间，
嗯，
去支持你的工作，
做你的这样一个后勤保障，
你是会不会考虑这些吧？
会的就答会。